our symbol you have red stars white
stars blue stars you don't have green
stars now why not you want me get it I
can't get it so loud okay
finally stumped with green stars off
it's exhausting there's no green in
space Oh No there's green space then
there's no green start there's plenty of
green wasn't probably whether the green
says fight or real piece of science and
you're like go okay fine
there's actually green emissions from
gas clouds on space and we looked at it
and we looked at its spectra we don't
know what it was and we is my historical
brethren in the field that I study and
in fact it was named of nebulae and it
was called nebulae mm-hmm this green
block this green light in space nebula
him there was a placeholder until we
actually figured out what it was we
figured out is actually oxygen behaving
in ways that we've never been able to
reproduce in the laboratory under the
under the rarefied vacuum of space
oxygen behaves badly we rode with
depending on how you want to look it's a
green cloud be coming for us it's so
it's a beautiful green light that if
you're if you're angstrom fluent is five
thousand and seven angstroms yeah on the
on the scale so you can have green light
coming from gas clouds but stars because
they're giving off a whole spectrum of
light green is this narrow part in the
middle of the spectrum and when you
puddle together all the light but you
can you can lean towards the red side of
the resin on a primary color
well because red orange yellow green
blue violet that whole spectrum get
either leans to the blue side and leans
to the red or gives about the same of
each and that will give you a blue star
red star or white star you're not going
to get a greens all right that's why
[Music]